hi my name is matcha minkovski I'm Liev
game designer for dying light today I'd
like to show you a brand new gameplay
for our upcoming expansion dying light
to following with this expansion we want
to introduce a new massive map
customizable buggies new weapons and new
mechanics this is also the first time
we're showing dying light the following
in coop alright let's take a look this
is the countryside and map bigger than
all the areas from the original game
combined Kyle is led to this part of
world by rumors of people who seemed
immune to the virus unfortunately the
people who were dealing with are very
close so in order to get any information
from them we need to show goodwill in
this particular situation we're informed
that the groundwaters has been
contaminated the community sent their
people to fix the problem but they never
came back if we can help them out they
might be willing to talk with us
countryside is vast and it's not safe to
travel by food so we're going to take
our buggies for a ride
our buggy is not just a mean of
transportation it's an essential tool
for survival and pretty awesome weapon
by the way it's also fully customizable
you can change its looks so liveries and
paint jobs but also add interesting
modifications like an electric cage
which you'll be able to observe later
now to get access to these toys you need
to level up your driving skill tree you
get driving points for performing
actions with your buggy like speeding
smashing zombies and jumping off ramps
and so on when you get it enough points
you level up and you get a skill point
that you can span on various unlocks ok
so we arrived at the pumping station now
let's just get rid of these zombies and
here's a perfect example of how our cage
works there you go pretty sweet and
useful thing that's also one of our new
weapons and not so new but still very
cool drop kick alright let's just kill
these guys
gone okay so now we can talked with
whoever is in charge around here I'm
over here Fred every new customer is a
blessing you're actually selling
something out of anger could he still
clear no diary afterwards tasteless if
an angel stepped on your tongue huh one
gallon for ten pounds of food we accept
gold as well ten pounds of food for
water when you start charging for air or
two oh we got does a Hagler look down
there Punk see that that's Rosco we
turned Hagler's over to him still want
to haggle huh you fat dog I might let
you trade your ride for some water [ __ ]
you [ __ ] so be it
alright so the bandits didn't want to
cooperate so are we gonna do it the
painful way
and that's a great opportunity to show
you one of our new guns we look closely
at what our community wants you guys
wanted more guns we're happy to deliver
all right now let's shoot it
SMG is only one of the new cool weapons
this is my personal favorite crossbow
and now that everyone's dead we can head
inside
dying light the following also
introduces new variants of enemies like
this guy as you can see he's wearing a
bulletproof armor
so it's not that simple to kill him but
we're in Cobb we're gonna cooperate
stager and precise headshot okay so
let's help that dude
just a zero sent me well pesky did
you're one of the three who got lost the
only one left I am Ali they got thrown
to that that beast
okay listen Ali this place has to be at
least sort of operational otherwise the
bandits wouldn't have had any water the
bandits have water here but there is
none at the farm
perhaps we can redirect it alright so
now we should be able to send water back
to the farm it's not working why is it
not working
oh [ __ ] but nothing's ever dot simple
apparently there's a problem with water
pressure it's [ __ ] ancient pipes burst
we are all well and truly flat I'll get
the van as Ali poetically noted if the
pus burst we're truly in deep trouble
with a pipeline but [ __ ] sake hurry
the clock is ticking we've got to fix
this as soon as possible we're gonna run
them back to our rides
one of our buggies was bit low on fuel
so this time around both of us gonna run
in a single buggy
the buggy offers certain level of
protection but it doesn't make you
invincible you still have to watch out
for exploding bumpers as you can see
vitals can be dangerous to drift brake
and smash the environment to get rid of
them it is also important to watch your
fuel gauge because being stocking to
open probably want and well if you need
gas you can retrieve it from cars
abandoned in the countryside by the way
as you hit obstacles and zombies the
parts in your ride wear off so
eventually you'll need to repair them or
exchange for better ones
pipeline ends here honey sparking on
okay we're at the pumping station now to
stop the leakage
water level is already rising so we
gotta hold our breath
okay
job well done Ally I got it but the
place was already flooded so now what we
just we just wait yes now it should just
be a matter of time so we're good
I'm better than good I think you just
saved all our asses get back to the farm
I'll tell Jessie you're all right you
know forest ranger now we could head
back to the farm but we have a random
encounter let's check that out
the only problem is while we were inside
it got dark and let me tell you the
night into following it's even scarier
than in the base game
if you're not we've got new toys to
counter that one of my personal
favorites the flamethrower
and one more zap from the electric cage
and some help from our shot
alright here we are last thing to do is
to retrieve the package and go home
safely
or not
and that's it that sighing light the
following it's coming out worldwide on
February 9th thank you so much bye-bye